how's it going everybody it's Warren
welcome back to my channel the cosmic
wonder where we talk about all things
Marvel and everything relating to the
MCU
although phase four has unfortunately
been delayed and is off to a very slow
start there's a lot to look forward to
many movies many shows and a lot of new
characters that are going to be
introduced to the Marvel Cinematic
Universe and although not every single
movie in show is going to introduce a
very big character some are going to be
sideline characters but some are going
to introduce key characters for the
future of the MCU and these are projects
like the one division series Doctor
Strange and the multiverse of madness
and Thor love and thunder and today
we're going to be talking about a famous
Thor character that could be making his
debut in Thor love and thunder if not
very soon after and that is beta ray
bill
now of course fans have been waiting for
beta ray bill to enter the MCU for a
pretty long time now and it looks like
it's finally happening so I'll break
down everything that you need to know in
this video if you're new be sure to
subscribe to stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter this week's giveaway for a
chance to win a fan OHS Funko pop all
you got to do to enter is subscribe like
this video and leave a comment down
below so today we have a new report from
Mikey Sutton talking about beta ray bill
making his MCU debut it appears that
he's heard a little bit of information
about beta ray bill and Marvel Studios
his plans for him and here's what he's
reporting he says Jane Foster will not
be the only one worthy of holding mule
near Thor love and thunder is enveloped
in mystery despite rampant speculation
of certain characters appearing the
Silver Surfer was debunked not too long
ago but beta ray bill remains a question
mark according to my key sources beta
ray bill will be coming to the MC
without a doubt whether that will be in
Thor love and thunder is still an
unanswered question nevertheless it
seems quite likely however there is one
thing that is supposedly inevitable beta
ray bill will take mule near away from
Thor written and illustrated by Walt
Simonson in the Mighty Thor number 337
in 1983 that Abe you of beta ray bill is
considered one of the comics all-time
game changers and Marvel Studios has
been wanting to adapt the story arc for
years now and fans may see it sooner
than you
so there are a few key things to talk
about here that are really important one
is that Taika Waititi the director of
thor ragnarok and the upcoming thor love
and thunder has been pretty open about
beta ray bill he said several times that
he doesn't know if he's going to put
beta ray bill in the movie or not the
script is very fluid and is always
changing but if he can find a good story
for him he will include him and let's
not forget that he did put the beta ray
bill Easter egg in Thor Ragnarok on
Sekar where they had all the statues of
the champions we saw a statue of the
head of beta ray bill or at least
another korbinite which is the race of
beta ray bell and then in avengers
endgame there was another Easter Egg for
beta ray bill the directors and writers
confirmed that the scene where nebula
and Gamora
are fighting back in 2014 takes place on
at Corbin the korbinite homeworld so
nebula Gomorrah and Thanos army was
fighting the korbinites and it's
possible that beta ray bill could have
been on that planet at that time so it's
very clear that Marvel Studios does want
him in the MCU such as Mikey said now
the other big thing about this report is
that he's going to take mule near from
Thor now this is somewhat of an
adaptation of the comic when he was
introduced when he was introduced he
immediately fought Thor and two Thor
surprise and everybody else's surprise
beta ray bill was actually able to lift
and wield mule near Thor and beta ray
bill would eventually make it back to
Asgard where beta ray bill demanded that
he keep mule near as a prize Odin then
had the two of them fight to the death
and the winner would keep mule near now
beta ray bill basically won although he
did save Thor's life and Thorton and
died and in return instead of Odin
giving him Mjolnir he made a new hammer
for him storm breaker
now of course this is not what happened
in the MCU we saw for make Stormbreaker
plus the handle is made of groot but
beta ray bill is going to need a hammer
if he's going to be introduced and it
sounds like he's going to be taking mule
near from Thor and also lady Thor since
Jane Foster is going to become Thor and
willed Muni Rin for love and thunder
again it's not confirmed that beta ray
bill will be in for love and thunder and
it sounds like tyka doesn't really know
yet but one thing that is for sure is
that beta ray bill will be entering the
MCU
very soon so
let me know what you think about this
report and about beta ray bill entering
the MCU and let me know what you would
like to see from beta ray bill
story-wise leave all your thoughts down
below don't forget to like this video
and subscribe to stay up-to-date on
everything relating to the MCU for live
updates you can follow me on Twitter and
as always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof